llevan en kabul casi dos meses huyeron
de sus casas a raíz de los
enfrentamientos que sacuden el país
desde la toma del poder de los taibanes
pero el nuevo gobierno dijo que tendrán
que volver a sus casas
tomamos la decisión de mandarlos de
vuelta porque el Gobierno no tiene
presupuesto suficiente por eso pedimos a
todas las ong localizadas en kabul que
nos ayudarán
hasta el momento han ordenado el regreso
de más de mil familias desplazadas la
mayoría permanecían en un campamento
informal de la capital muchas temen en
la llegada del invierno y el aumento de
la violencia terrorista en la provincia
Norteña de conduz tras el reciente
atentado en una mezquita chiíta
miren jotitán estoy nerviosa porque
nuestra casa fue destrozada y el
invierno se acerca no tenemos leña
necesitamos agua y comida soy mujer cómo
lo puedo solucionar dónde voy a
encontrar todas estas cosas
mientras la realidad de los que lograron
salir del país con la llegada de los
talibanes es muy distinta en Alemania
miles de afganos esperan los vuelos
hacia su destino final Estados Unidos
esta ha sido una operación dirigida por
el estado desde el principio pero solo
somos una especie de músculo detrás de
ella grandes organizaciones como la Cruz
Roja e incluso comunidades locales han
sido increíbles en todo
en medio de la crisis política económica
y social de la nación según acnur se
espera que al menos medio millón de
refugiados afganos huyan a países
vecinos sumándose a los 2,2 millones que
ya lo han hecho